if we do sine x equals minus 1 over 2
okay this time I wonder if you can tell
me straight up without reaching for your
calculator what's our basic small angle
it's going to be failure is right
because you're thinking site X equal to
half your first solution is 30 I want
science to be negative in which
quadrants is so negative 3 and 4 you see
that three input so my solutions will be
180 plus 30 or 360 takeaway study
there's my third and fourth quadrant
solutions right to 10 or three found out
sensors he does it it all right last one
I'm going to run off my first one the
reason why through this guy in here is
because you won't always get these exact
tally ones that I've been handing you
right 30 40 50 60 degrees they're all
nice and neat that five over 11 there
that's just kind of a bit random really
sorry yes ah can never be negative they
absolutely can be negative we'll get
into that in a second for example see
how this one was 135 for 315 and I said
you could get forward and get 495 right
there's nothing stopping us because
we're going round and round a circle
right you can go the other way if you
like what would have been the previous
answer before this it'll be negative 45
degrees i'm just taking away 180 right
you can put this in your calculator 10
of negative 45 and sure enough you get
negative 1 and the reason why I ignored
this solution and this solution is
because right the outset I asked you and
commonly this is what happens please
solve in between these aims from north
to 360 which are all positive okay but
there's nothing stopping you in fact
I've been deliberately avoiding these
questions because they're less common
because they don't want to confuse you
too much but sometimes this guy be
different they might give you something
like this right which is deliberately
saying look I want some of the negative
solutions
I want some of the answers that are over
here like minus 45 or minus 90 135 and
on an overnight okay so yes anglers
community which sounds a bit crazy when
you just start from right angle
triangles like so because how can you
have a negative angle in there but it's
not so crazy when you think about the
unit circle and going that way or going
that way no reason why you can't go
clockwise already so as a bit of
spoiling though you don't need to be
aware of any of that kind of girl feels
last question five if cos x equals 5 /
11 right we're definitely going to need
our calculators for this so what acute
angle to the nearest degree are you
getting 63 cancer x equals 63 so what do
I do with 63 cause is supposed to be
positive so which quadrants are
interested in positive right so I think
it's going to be first involved yeah
because all the little positive here and
cause is positive here if I change it to
be cos x equals negative 5 over then I'd
be any other two quadrants okay all
right so therefore being that I want
first and fourth quadrant I'm going to
say it's x is equal to 63 or what's my
fourth quadrant angle ah fourth
quadrants yeah I'm 360 yeah okay so it's
gonna be sorry you've given me the air
Tori how you it's going to be 297 yeah
there we are okay and again you can pop
either those into your calculator
because we've approximate it a long way
that's 63 I assume has some decimal
places after it we're not going to get
exactly 5 / 11 the way we've got exactly
it is or exactly this but it's close
enough to a modular power alright any
questions on those before we move on yes
can read more than to us okay so you you
might have noticed like frequently I'm
getting a pair answers para Vance's pair
of answers most commonly you will
however and this is where I'm going to
appeal to the graph um you don't always
get two solutions I want you to have a
look
for example this is the example I gave
you before so suppose I last you saw
sine x equals something some number okay
now usually you get two solutions and
it's really easy to see why right every
time see how i draw our horizontal line
across which represents whatever number
of thing is equal to okay if i draw a
horizontal line here or here or here i'm
getting two solutions every time do you
notice that one two one two one two it
always seems to be a pair but there are
some alternatives for instance i'm going
to draw it again because starting to get
a bit busy to stay right there are two
places i wonder if you can guess them
there are two places I can draw through
where I do not get two solutions I
totally get one can anyone see them on
the knives one sale yeah yeah very good
sir come if the line I drew draw through
is just high enough that it just touches
there which is one right or just low
enough that it only touches there which
is negative one lo and behold I only
have one solution right namely this one
or this one okay um last week I think or
do they can't remember there is one
particular point that I can draw a line
through and I don't get two or one I get
three solutions where's that little yeah
right down the middle I go right across
there I'm hit it once twice three times
it's the only spot by the way that does
that right I'm still again I could get
two solutions that's the most frequent I
can get one solution is couple of spots
I can get three solutions right down the
middle I can draw a whole bunch of
places where i get no solutions where
the green light never intercepted the
blue loan in fact there's an infinite
number of them like down here maybe
rights in that guy he just tracks log he
never intersects with the blue line in
fact the glue i could go on forever and
it's never going to get that low or
alternatively it's never going to get
that high right so do you remember ah
few lessons back when we said the range
of Sun
is from negative 1 to 1 right so she put
in negative 2 and a gear 3 or 20 or 25
you're never going to get a solution
because you're never in that range okay
so yes they can be more sometimes
they're or less that's why the graph is
so useful right I said this is kind of
handy it's kind of quick right but it
doesn't show you what's all going on
right so that's why it's the 10 and have
it you sleep but this is that